talk about how when we mentioned earlier
things hit critical mass and just sort
of the things align and it I momentum
Bylsma yes what starts with doing the
work but the work has to be of high
quality but you have to put it out into
the world and get specially people who
are on your wavelengths but the fun fun
part is that there are people if you're
doing work that as honesty and it's well
made and has and communicates where
you're trying to communicate there are
people all up and down the food chain in
Hollywood from from from people who are
kind of marginal to people who are
incredibly successful who will resonate
to your work will respond to it the
challenge is that getting it in front of
them and so it's very important
interests of doing the work to target
the people who are doing work that you
admire I always suggested people that
they make a list of a hundred writers
directors actors producers even studio
executives who are doing the work that
they most admire so for instance if you
see a TV show and you like it add that
those names to your list then particular
if you're in Los Angeles or New York or
any major cities with cities but
particularly LA show that list your
friends and say if you see these people
any of these names giving talks
appearing on panels let me know because
then you can go to those places and you
can talk to those people you can meet
them and you can start to establish
connection and and then they get to be
curious about you and then then if you
still have done this feature you know
here you know it's a then 11 the great
rules are polywood is that everybody
needs to read so script is a very quiet
and a very obnoxious object so it's like
oh do I really have to read that script
but if you say I've made a film it's
much easier and or even if it is short
where people can just put it in the DVD
player or click it you know on online or
whatever you can watch it be kind of an
immediate experience your it's a much
better commercial for you as a creative
artist than just a script and I speak sm
one who's actually sold a lot of scripts
you know and
hundreds of hours of produce credits so
so I've been successful pitching script
selling scripts all that stuff but I'm
much favor making the thing itself
because when you make the thing itself
it's such a better advertisement for you
first of all and secondly you're no
longer auditioning you're actually
creating work but but you can't just
create the work and expect the work
magically to find its audience so that's
where you have to do the heavy lifting
but the cool part is and thanks to the
Internet everyone is checking stuff out
and the moment as very permeable so the
moment someone who's a buddy of JJ
Abrams emails JJ's ISM you got to check
this out you will it has to be someone
he knows but then you never know if you
just start putting out in the world to
the people you know particular you know
there's gonna be a ripple effect and
even with Space Command that's what's
been happening where people know about
it people have heard about it and and
it's just you know so then it's just
really doing recognizing the part of
your job is creating the working part of
your job is getting the work out there
and most artists don't want to do that
second part they think oh it's hard you
know I don't want to do that particular
writers it's like I want to sit in my
room and type and I don't want to talk
to people you know well you know tough
you know you either get some get a
partner who's very outgoing or learn
those skills because it is a very
frustrating life to write scripts
endlessly and have them
nowhere and so you should not allow that
to be acceptable in your career in your
life and you have to be the good to be
the guy that pushes the rock of the
mount and it's funny if a couple years
ago I made a Star Trek episode without
studio or network it was called star
trek new voyages world enough in time
and it starts George Takei and it was a
full hour-long episode we made it in
2007 2008 got nominated for the hugo and
the nebula and but it was very difficult
and my monitor myself while i was i
co-wrote and directed and executive
produced it and my mantra to myself
while I was making it was I'm made of
iron and nothing will stop me and I
found that I need to really live by that
to get that made and so if you take
something like that on and if you're
determined gets the finish line no
matter what then it simply becomes a
question of how do I do this how do I
make it possible who do I
to affiliate with what and what do I
need to remove that isn't necessary and
and you'll be very clearly trying to
accomplish because most people get
stopped most people get stuck most
people go nowhere and you have to have a
very keen eye that's what the problem is
to be able to fix it so that's part of
it
you